[Music]
she's the first one in the room and the
last to leave that's what mark anthony
said about
j-lo who's the cover girl for instyle's
new beauty issue
and leave it to ben affleck to ask what
we all wonder about the 51 year old
where are you keeping the fountain of
youth why do you look the same as you
did in 2003 and it kind of looks like
i'm in my 40s
at
[Music]
jen's best of flirty response finn is
funny
he still looks pretty good too also
looking good
katy perry who gave this beauty
confession on american idol
as a new mother i don't have very much
time so i've quit shaving my legs
but when you sang the hair on my legs
grew an inch and a half
so full body chills
she literally has leg hair thank you for
the forensic report
night fellow new mom and season five
runner-up catherine mcphee returned to
idol as a mentor
37 year old was schooled learning some
gen z lingo from a contestant
how old are you 19 and 10 days i wasn't
quite oh we're both aries
[Music]
oh my god is that a you know like a
young person thing
and let's just say this is a miley thing
cyrus rocked the ncaa final four stage
this weekend
[Music]
she sang seven covers and original songs
during a 17 minute and 53 second
performance
after also performing at the super bowl
pregame many wonder
will the super bowl halftime show be
next i came in like
i watched every bit of that concert and
i thought she was fantastic by the way
next year super bowl will be played
right here in la at the home of the rams
and the chargers
[Music]